The joe rogan experience I went to,
I was uh,
when I was a seal recruiter,
I got invited to mit smart ass
motherfuckers there,
man,
I'm not that on the cigarette animal
dming knuckle dragger and um,
he was just guide the,
I forget his name but he was like the
top head head guy,
old white guy,
you know,
all,
all genius doubt.
And we were on this panel and they were
asking us all these questions about the
mind,
mental toughness and shit.
He was answering them and I wasn't
answering any questions and I'll never
forget he was just answered them off of
theory.
He never put his fucking ass and shit.
You read a bunch of fucking books and
you think that you know how to fucking
mine works and shit.
I had gone through hell to get the kid
and then all the way up until now.
So I know.
So that theory is bullshit.
Yeah,
there's a lot of good stuff out there.
You can read from people,
but I had lived hell and when you put
yourself in hill,
that's the only time you can figure out
how the fuck to get through that
motherfucker.
You can't,
you can't read somebody else's book
about some theory on how to do shit.
Some guy who set up in there a nice warm
office in [inaudible] and wrote some
book with a Nice Cup of coffee in the
fucking hand.
No,
I want to see that guy who immerse
themselves in fucking hell and he
thought about quitting and leaving and
and,
and his wife and his kids.
And why am I here?
It says,
is it worth it?
All this crazy shit.
It still said if found out a way to get
through it.
So basically that's the,
that's the bottom line of it all.
We all want to read about how we can
quickly get somewhere.
That's why there's six minute abs and
all sorts of Shit.
So powerful did you may get some results
from it,
but they're not permanent.
The permanent result comes from you
fucking,
I say it all time.
You have to suffer.
You have to make that a tattoo on your
fucking brain.
So when that hard time comes again,
you don't forget it.
You may forget it for a second,
but you can go back in the cookie jar.
I call it.
It's a,
it's something that we've all endured.
I call it the cookie jar and we often
forget how hard we are,
but you got to reflect back,
take a couple of seconds,
reflect,
I've been through this,
I've been through that and then remind
yourself I'm a bad motherfucker and then
you can get through that shit.
But if you don't believe it,
you haven't endorsed Shit,
you're just blowing smoke.
Man.
I think there is a lesson because I
think that what we did actually was,
um,
fairly simple,
which was we played it by ear and the
stuff that didn't work,
we chucked it.
And the stuff that did work,
we augmented it.
And so there are no hard and fast rules.
Yeah.
You're also banking people.
You're both very unusually smart and
open minded with each other.
We found each other.
I think open mindedness point,
important and smart.
In this case,
I didn't like being able to look at each
other with compassion.
You know,
this is true for any interaction,
right?
Let's,
Oh,
can I look at you and see you as a human
being with real emotions and feelings
and reality to your experiences as well,
even if I feel like we disagree
completely.
So even,
you know,
even when we're at our angriest with
each other,
if we can see each other's humanity
through it and you get through.
Yeah.
Dot.
That is a lesson for every human being
in all walks of life,
in any situation.
When you disagree with someone,
not just your lover,
not just a friend,
but people that you don't even know,
it's,
it's very easy to dehumanize someone who
disagrees with you.
And I think to bring this all back
around,
this is a part of the problem with a
male female interaction today is this
dehumanization on both sides.
That the men are demons,
that the woman are this and the men of
that.
And it's all this,
you know,
it's these rash generalizations in this
extreme tribalism.
Well,
yes.
Um,
there is kind of a secret weapon and I,
it's not going to seek it out.
The secret is,
uh,
heather and I have a whole second
channel on which to navigate,
which is that we both know the same
evolutionary story.
Yeah.
There's a way,
you know,
here's a,
an idea that's important.
You can very often understand more about
a given human interaction,
especially a contentious one if you turn
down the sound,
right?
So you can't hear what's being said and
that sounds wrong,
right?
Sounds like,
well,
maybe the most important piece of
information you could have is what these
people are saying to each other as
they're arguing.
But no,
that's not how human beings work.
Sometimes the important information is
on that vocal channel and sometimes the
vocal channel is actually almost purely
noise.
Right?
And so if both literally and
metaphorically,
but if heather and I both know that,
then there's a part of us that's sort of
always outside if we,
I mean,
we don't fight that much.
It's really pretty rare.
But,
um,
when we do,
there's also a part of us that's
watching the interaction and um,
knows that a certain pattern may have to
unfold in order for us to get to the
other part of it.
You know,
sometimes heather needs to be engaging
in theater at some level,
even though neither of us wants to be.
That's a great way to put it.
Engaging in couples theater.
It is,
and it is,
it's actually,
it's the perfect example of this thing.
Like,
you know,
you're talking about Peterson and go
into work and wearing makeup and you
think,
am I sending sexual signals?
Will,
Gosh,
we're all involved in weird stuff.
Right?
The idea that you and your mate could
both be aware that your argument is in
some,
in some way theater and that even,
you know,
you might think,
well,
if it's theater,
we can just skip it.
No,
you can't.
No.
There are things that have to happen in
order for you to get to the next act.
There were so many of those guys.
I mean,
how many did we start out with that were
alcoholics or former alcoholics?
Yeah.
Fucking everybody.
All of them.
Yeah.
And they're all,
and that was the thing about when you
were an open or a Boston,
it was like the criteria,
where are you funny enough to cover 15
minutes to open number two,
do you have a functioning automobile
that you can take these Dui headliners
to the Gig with?
Because none of them had licenses.
So I can remember like picking up Gavin
pickin up,
Sweeney picking up Mike Mcdonald's and
having to drive these guys out to
wherever and then you couldn't leave
early cause you were driving them home.
They'd give you a few bucks for gas and
you were happy to do it.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to be in a car with don yet.
And so one time nick's Nick's comedy.
Stop calling me up and they're like,
you're working in Framingham.
You get to drive the feature and the
headliner out.
And I go downtown to pick them up in
front of Nick's and I've got a a,
I had a 1976 Volkswagen Rabbit,
four cylinder rusted out floorboards and
I get down there and it's Mike Sullivan
Irwin who weighed about 300 pounds and
John Pinette who is about to 75 and they
saw my car and they both started
giggling like schoolgirls like we're
going to fucking go to a Gig and this
car.
So we've,
we pack them in and as I couldn't get
on,
I couldn't get the car going above like
40 so instead of taking the mass pike at
west of Framingham,
I had to take a route nine the whole
way.
The open,
get it packed.
Hilarious.
Like you carrying lumber on the roof.
Fucking 800 pounds of humans in my car.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Was this stupid ad you have to watch for
the Olympics there?
Boy,
I'm,
this Olympics is,
I think I'm going to say this.
I think the Olympics are gross.
This is why I think the Olympics are
gross.
I think it's a great opportunity for all
those athletes.
I think it's great for people to watch
it,
but I think it is a fucking disgusting
money grab and all those amateur air
quotes.
Athletes don't get paid shit and these
companies are making billions and
billions of dollars off of them and I
really wish they would all quit.
I really wished they would say,
fuck you pay me.
I really wished they would just go
straight ray Liotta they give you pain.
Me,
they'd get up there.
They're youth for the,
not only that,
the fucking companies,
they're so restrictive,
they're the IOC and all the people that
are behind it are so restrictive and
they are making ungodly sums of money,
ungodly contracts.
They're just giant contracts to air the,
the Olympics,
giant amounts of money to build the
stadiums and set up.
These are these events and that
everything is about net nationalism and
national pride,
whether it's in Korea or Russia or
wherever the fuck they do them.
But meanwhile the athletes don't get
dick.
They don't get Dick.
If you're lucky and you're Michael
Phelps,
he become famous out of it and you get a
bunch of commercials,
commercials and endorsements and you
make a shit load of money that way.
But how many Michael Phelps are there?
There's a three or four.
I mean how many,
but how many in the,
all the,
all the Olympics and out of all the
Olympics.
Jamie,
you're a sports fan at all the Olympics,
say like the Olympics this year.
Well,
let's go the last one.
Who the fuck came out of it?
Where they're a household name?
Oh yeah.
Right now you've got shaun white and
maybe I heard of that guy.
The girl that won,
uh,
Kim is her last name on the border.
Right.
Bronze last night or two nights before
the real famous.
There's Lindsey Vaughn,
she's very famous.
She's very famous that she,
she used to date tiger woods.
Yeah.
That made her famous too.
Plus she's hot.
That makes her famous.
It's peekaboo street shit.
Interesting names.
So like helped her.
She's a gold medal winner,
I believe.
How many other ones are there is a few.
I mean,
it's just like a handful.
They can build a story around someone
and then they cancel story.
But when you get to the point where it's
worthwhile to sacrifice your entire life
and it actually pays off,
what are the,
what are the odds?
It's so fucking small.
But meanwhile people are tuning in to
all of it.
They're making massive amounts of
revenue from all of it.
And they're not sharing it with the
athletes at all.
I think it's fucking gross.
They pretend it's amateur,
different tenants and amateur.
It's a Goddamn motherfucking business.
That's what the Olympics are.
Well about college business too.
You can shit basketball and football.
Really?
NCAA says student athletes shouldn't be
paid because the 13th amendment allows
unpaid prison labor.
What the fuck?
Oh,
that's Shaun King.
This is great.
This is a,
this is another article.
This was the main,
main one going around.
But there's uh,
uh,
that's crazy.
Did they really say that?
The 13th amendment,
which allows unpaid prison labor,
they decided in a lawsuit a response to
a motion to dismiss and they,
that's what they use this though.
So disgusting.
They're so disgusting.
They're the same to me.
Ncaa College football and basketball,
same thing to me.
They have 180 of those hundred thousand
people.
Yeah.
Fuck you pay those guys,
pay him,
pay those girls,
pay all those athletes.
You're making money,
you're making money,
and you're not sharing it with the
athletes.
They might as well be slaves.
They might as well be fucking prisoners,
the Olympics,
Ncaa,
all that shit.
It's just these no way.
There's no way you could do that fresh
today.
Have you started from scratch today and
said,
we're going to get make billions of
dollars and we're going to give you uhmm
God.
Gotcha.
Cool.
There was no way.
Yeah.